hace algunos vídeos que mencioné que
cualquier cosa elevada a la potencia
cero es igual a 1
así x elevada a la cero es igual a 1 y
te dio un argumento del por qué se
cumple esto use el siguiente ejemplo si
tenemos que 3 elevado a la potencia 1 es
igual a 3 3 al cuadrado es igual a 9 3
al cubo es igual a 27 cada que vamos
disminuyendo la potencia en 1 estamos
viviendo entre 3 27 entre 13 es igual a
99 entre 3 es igual a 3 entonces 3 entre
13 es igual a 1 y eso debe ser lo que
resulta de 3 elevado a la cero potencia
eso es una manera de verlo la otra
manera es que necesitamos esto para que
las leyes de exponentes funcionen
adecuadamente por ejemplo sabemos que ha
elevado al ave por ha elevado la c esto
es igual por la ley de los exponentes
al ave más
ahora qué pasa cuando tenemos ha elevado
a la vez por la ala cero
esto es aplicando esta ley ha elevado a
la b + 0 y esto es igual a ha elevado a
la b ahora qué pasa cuando esto lo
dividimos entre a al ave cuando esto lo
dividimos entre al ave vamos a hacerlo
por acá al ave por al acero usando esta
propiedades puede ser igual
al ave correcto demás héroes ve ahora
dividiendo ambos lados entre ha elevado
al ave que nos queda del lado izquierdo
nos queda simplemente ha elevado a cero
esto se cancela y por tanto ha elevado a
la cero es igual a 1 y puedes usar un
argumento similar en la gran mayoría de
las propiedades de los exponentes para
concluir que siempre que le vas algo a
la potencia 0 obtienes 1 y también hace
sentido lo que hemos visto que a medida
que dividimos entre 3 vamos a
incrementarlo por 1 nuestro exponente
esto sigue funcionando cuando tomas 3
elevado a la potencia menos 1
vimos en un vídeo pasado que esto es
igual a 1 sobre 3 elevado a la potencia
1 o un tercio
así de nueva cuenta así de 3 a la cero a
un tercio está dividiendo por tres
realmente hace sentido que 3 elevado a
la potencia cero es igual a 1 sin
embargo hay un pequeño resquicio que
pasa con 0 elevado a la cero esto es
realmente un concepto muy extraño 0
multiplicado por sí mismo 0 veces y esto
depende del contexto en el que lo estés
usando en algunas ocasiones se
establecerá que es indefinido pero la
mayor de las veces por lo menos en lo
que yo he visto esto está definido como
uno entonces definido como uno y la
razón del por qué esto aunque esto no es
totalmente intuitivo si quieres puedes
teclear en google 0 elevado a la cero y
vas a obtener uno aún así esto no es
para nada intuitivo la razón por la cual
esto se define así es que hace que
muchísimas fórmulas funcionen en
particular la fórmula el binomio
funciona para los coeficientes binomial
es no va a realizar esto aquí pero ahí
se verifica que 0 elevado a la cero
potencia es igual a 1 esto realmente es
algo interesante para reflexionar que
podría esto significa por lo pronto
revisemos
las otras propiedades luego podemos
resumirlas junto con algunos problemas
de ejemplo en el último vídeo vimos qué
es lo que significa elevar a una
potencia negativa por ejemplo a elevada
a la potencia menos uno o más en general
a la menos b esto es igual a 1 sobre a
la b veamos esto con un par de ejemplos
en concreto 3 elevado a la menos 3 es
igual a 1 sobre 3 al cubo lo cual a su
vez es igual a 1 sobre tres por tres por
tres y esto es igual a 1 sobre 27 ahora
si te pregunto si te pregunto a que es
igual 1 sobre 3 un tercio elevado a la
potencia menos 2 esto es igual a 1 sobre
un tercio elevado al cuadrado el signo
negativo desaparece tomando el recíproco
y esto es igual a 1 sobre
un tercio al cuadrado es un noveno y
esto es igual uno sobre un noveno es uno
por nueve finalmente esto es igual a
nueve y esto hace sentido porque
recuerda que vimos que un tercio es
igual a tres a la menos 13 a la menos
uno por la propia de los exponentes es
igual a un tercio
uno sobre tres a la 1 y esto si lo
sustituimos aquí tenemos que es igual a
3 a la menos 1 elevado a la menos 2
estas dos cosas son equivalentes y si
usamos una de las propiedades que
aprendimos en el primer vídeo podemos
tomar el producto de estos dos
exponentes así que esto resulta 3
elevado a la menos 1 por menos 2 es
decir 3 a la 2 3 al cuadrado lo cual es
igual a 9 es realmente sorprendente como
todas estas propiedades de los
exponentes se encajan en un maravilloso
rompecabezas donde nunca se contradicen
entre sí no importa cuál propiedad
dulces al final de cuentas va a obtener
la misma respuesta mientras no hagas
algo disparatado ahora
lo último que quiero definir es el
concepto de un exponente fraccionario
entonces si tengo algo elevado un
exponente fraccionario pongamos que
tengo
elevado a la 1 / b y esto lo va a
definir va a ser igual a la raíz pésima
de a déjame ser muy claro en esto para
esto hagamos algunos ejemplos numéricos
aquí si tenemos que 4 elevado a la un
medio esto es igual a la raíz cuadrada
la raíz cuadrada de 4 y esto es igual
tomando la raíz principal la raíz
cuadrada de 4 la red principal de 4 es
igual a 2 tratemos de aclarar más esto
si ahora tenemos que 8 está elevado a la
potencia un tercio este lo mismo que
tomar la raíz cúbica de 8 y esto es algo
que en ocasiones puede ser confuso al
trabajar con exponentes lo que quiero
calcular aquí es cuál es el número que
si lo multiplicó por si mismo tres veces
es igual a 8 entonces a ver vamos a
averiguar esto por acá si yo establezco
que x es igual a 8 elevada a la un
tercio lo cual es equivalente a x al
cubo es igual a 8 y como sé que estas
dos expresiones son equivalentes a
partir de que x es igual a 8 a la un
tercio elevamos al cubo ambos lados al
elevar al cubo ambos lados del lado
izquierdo tengo x al cubo y del lado
derecho que obtenemos 8 al a un tercio
por 3 un tercio por 3 es igual a 18 a la
1 es igual a 8 entonces
es igual a 8 al un tercio cuál es el
valor de x bueno x va a ser 2 por 2 por
2 lo cual es igual a 8 no hay una manera
sencilla de hacer esto una vez que te
vas a la cuarta raíz o a la quinta raíz
que tienes decimales probablemente en
esta es una calculadora para hacer esto
pero cosas como 8 elevada a la un tercio
o 16 elevada a un cuarto o 27 a la un
tercio esas no son difíciles de calcular
así que en este caso déjame precisarlo
esto es igual a 2 bien hagámoslo un poco
más confuso hagamos digamos 27 elevado a
la menos un tercio no te preocupes
vamos a hacerlo paso a paso para que
veas que no es tan difícil cuando
tenemos un exponente negativo esto es
equivalente a recordemos esto es igual a
1 sobre
27 elevado a la potencia un tercio estas
dos son equivalentes para eliminar un
exponente negativo simplemente tomas uno
sobre el número y entonces a que es
igual 27 a la potencia un tercio es
decir cuando uno multiplicado por sí
mismo tres veces es igual a 27 el número
es 3 así es que este número va a ser
igual a 1 sobre 3 no estuvo tan
complicado sigamos subiendo el nivel
hagamos algo un poco más confuso algo
que puede ser más capciosa hagamos algo
más interesante que es igual
pongamos 8 elevado a la dos tercios 8 a
la potencia dos tercios asusté un poco
verdad pero en realidad lo único que
tienes que recordar es usar la regla de
los exponentes esto es igual a 8
8 elevado al cuadrado y esto a la vez
elevado a la un tercio y como sea eso sí
multiplico estos dos exponentes dos por
un tercio es igual a dos tercios
así es que ocho a la dos tercios es lo
mismo que o se eleva al cuadrado y luego
sacar la raíz cúbica de eso y esto
también lo podríamos ver como 8 eleva la
potencia un tercio y eso elevado al
cuadrado porque de cualquier manera que
multiplique estos exponentes siempre
obtengo 8 a la dos tercios o
verifiquemos esto verifiquemos que
obtenemos en ambos casos el mismo valor
aquí arriba que tenemos 8 al cuadrado es
igual a 64 elevado a un tercio y acá
abajo que tenemos 8 a la un tercio ya
vimos allá arriba que es la raíz cúbica
de 8 la cual es igual a 2 por lo cual
aquí tenemos 2 elevado al cuadrado ahora
a que es igual 64 un tercio el número
multiplicado por sí mismo tres veces es
igual a 64 bueno tenemos que cuatro por
cuatro por cuatro es igual a 64 es decir
4 al cubo es igual a 64 lo cual implica
que 4 es igual a 64
un tercio aquí tenemos entonces que esto
es igual a cuatro y mira qué suerte 2 al
cuadrado es igual a 4 también así que no
importa de qué manera lo haces puedes
tomar el cuadrado y luego la raíz cúbica
o puedes primero tomar la raíz cúbica y
después el cuadrado y vas a obtener
exactamente la misma respuesta ahora
bien hemos visto algunos ejemplos con
números para resumir lo que hemos hecho
voy a hacer algunos ejemplos
usando variables digamos entonces que
nos dan las siguientes expresiones y
queremos cerciorarnos que no haya
exponentes negativos en las respuestas
supongamos entonces que tenemos x a la
menos 3 sobre x a la menos 7 bueno una
manera de ver esto y hay varias maneras
de hacerlo pero una manera de hacer esto
es separarlo como x a la menos 3 x 1
sobre x a la menos 7 ya que es igual 1
sobre x a la menos 7 bueno uno sobre
quizá la menos 7 es igual a x a la
séptima de acuerdo si queremos
deshacernos de este 1 sobre x a la menos
7 hay que poner un signo negativo
pero menos -7 nos da x a la séptima así
que esto simplifica como x a la menos 3
x x a la séptima sumando los exponentes
obtenemos que esto es igual a x a la
cuarta potencia ahora otra manera para
haber resuelto esto es aplicando la
resta de exponentes podemos haber dicho
bueno consideremos que tenemos la misma
base por lo cual esto va a ser x elevado
a la menos tres menos menos siete bueno
menos tres menos menos siete eso es
menos 37 lo cual es igual a x a la
cuarta potencia y bueno una última
manera para haber hecho esto aunque
quizás no hay exactamente una última
manera sería x a la menos 3 sobre x a la
menos siete disculpa no es menos x a la
menos 7 x a la menos 7 y aquí que
hacemos x al menos 3 los estribos como 1
sobre x cúbica este x el a menos 31
sobre x cúbica por 1 sobre quizá la
menos 7 que hacemos aquí aplicamos la
ley de los exponentes en el denominador
que sería x a la 3
por equis menos siete esto va a ser
igual a 1 sobre 37 es igual a menos 4 x
a la menos 4 y finalmente esto si
queremos deshacernos de este recíproco
simplemente ponemos un signo negativo en
frente del exponente para obtener
finalmente que esto es igual a equis a
la cuarta entonces no importa la manera
de hacerlo mientras seamos consistentes
con las reglas siempre vamos a obtener x
a la cuarta hagamos uno un poco más
peliagudo y creo que ya habremos acabado
entonces supongamos que tenemos 3 x x al
cuadrado y esto x
elevado a la 3 medios todo esto / / x x
ya elevado a la un medio y esto es igual
a 3 que multiplica a pongamos los
términos en x x cuadrada sobre x que a
la vez multiplica ya la 3 medios sobre
ya un medio que a la 3 medios sobre ya
y esto aquí va a ser igual esto va a ser
igual a 3 por equis cuadradas sobre x o
x cuadrada sobre x a la 1 lo cual va a
ser igual a x a la 2 - 1 x cuadrados
sobre x a la 1 2 - 1 x ya a la 3 medios
menos un medio y finalmente esto que
resulta 3 x x a la 2 menos 121 es 1 no
ponemos el exponente 1 es simplemente x
x ya la 3 medios menos un medio 3 medios
menos un medio es dos medios dos medios
o dos mitades que es igual a 1 esto es
lo mismo que yo así que esto es igual a
3x y en fin te invito a que hagas
muchísimos más ejemplos de este tipo vas
a darte cuenta que usando las reglas que
hemos estado exponiendo en los últimos
vídeos puede simplificar cualquier
expresión con exponentes